but what do you think about what Tim
Cook did with apple would you put him at
the top as the best CEO in the market
today
when Steve Jobs died the market cap of
Apple was roughly 350 billion dollars
more or less now the market cap is what
1.1 trillion or two 1.22 million
something like that at one point so what
he did is uh is staggering
um I'd say apple reached three trillion
dollars at one point valuation what is
it right now by the way well it's it's
probably oh oh there you go 2.1 trillion
as of today okay so um so the the market
cap is now about uh four six seven times
what it was when he inherited the
company
um he did a spectacular job I've
interviewed him he's a terrific person
um I'd say right now there was a survey
done by the Wall Street Journal of who
was the best CEO today and he certainly
was one of the top I think Sacha Nadella
who's run Microsoft when he took over
Microsoft that company stock hadn't
moved in 10 years 10 years now the stock
is up like 10 times uh what he what he
did to make Microsoft much more valuable
than ever been is staggering so he is
one of the best CEOs out there in my
view and Tim Cook is another one Tom you
always talk about him you always give
credit to him yeah what's amazing is you
know whether you look at inflated
dollars or not I mean Tim Cook has
generated more shareholder value than
any CEO in the history of the American
experiment and it's just even if you
discount up for inflation and do all the
adjustments it's phenomenal spectacular
job he's done and remember when he took
over as CEO people didn't think he could
do this because he was not the Superstar
uh public figure that's that Steve Jobs
was but he was more mild-mannered he was
basically known as a supply chain person
but he's done a spectacular job and I
would say he
um and and such and Adele have both done
turnarounds or companies much more
valuable than they were before have you
read the book after Steve
no I have not you just came out if it's
a very very interesting book and most of
it is about Tim Cook very very
insightful he's uh uh I I know him
reason well I mean I was chairman of the
board of Duke I put him on the Duke
board and uh you know he he was a
graduate of the Duke University business
school so what all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got him
in white we got them in Black we got
them in red are black on black sold out
these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people were in the
office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign